if somebody walks
into the country right across the river
does somebody ask them to see
their vaccination card as individuals
come across the border
and they are both assessed for whether
they have uh any symptoms if they have
symptoms they are the intention is for
them to be quarantined that is our
process they're not intending to stay
here for a lengthy period of time i
don't think it's the same thing
yeah they always leave right away uh fox
news is peter ducey pressing the white
house on the status of covet testing for
migrants as border agents grapple with
more than 14 000 illegals taking shelter
just under a bridge in del rio joining
us now to react is republican texas
congressman dan crenshaw good morning to
you congressman good morning good
morning yeah you heard peter ducey
asking her about that you know if you go
over let's say you go to europe and you
come back into the country you have to
show that you have a coveted test when
you're at the airport yet we have all
these people coming in from the southern
border and they don't have to show any
any results
like the hypocrisy is is
really beyond the pale and one thing
that really stood out to me that saki
said is that well they don't intend to
stay here that long yeah
like everybody is trekking hundreds of
miles and paying off they're coming up
they're not they're not going to stay
here very long they're just day trippers
they'll be right out
and maybe just do some shopping no yeah
i don't think so i don't think that's
what's going on you know if you're if
you're a european you have to have a
vaccine before you can even come into
the united states if you're a u.s
citizen you have to get a covet test
before you come back into the u.s but if
you're an illegal immigrant you don't
have to have any of that and we'll give
you a hotel we'll give you free
transportation and if you're lucky the
democrats are also trying to give you a
green card and a pathway to citizenship
so it's a pretty good deal if you just
skirt our laws and cut in front of the
line of everybody else in the world who
possibly has a valid asylum claim to our
country
and i was reading this morning um
congressman you know
the administration is going to welcome
international travelers if they show the
vaccination
record starting in november
but what's going on on our southern
border right now you know has been going
on for a while during the covid pandemic
but what's interesting is all the people
from europe we would love to have them
come over because they're bringing
billions of dollars in tourist money to
places like new york city and and your
state and things like that so we want
those people over but you're right the
double standard is just a head scratcher
well the in the irony of her statement
about that again was the people who are
actually day trippers the the short
length of vacationers those are actually
you know europeans those are actually
people from around the world uh the
people who are crossing our border are
intending to stay and look at this
there's like 50 000 people who have
crossed and don't even have a court date
don't even have a court date so there's
zero chance they'll show up for a court
date that they don't even have they're
definitely intending to stay and the
people who do have a court date only
about 13 have showed up for that at all
there's hundreds of thousands of people
being let loose into the interior with
no way to track them no way to get them
back and no way to enforce our laws it's
it's this is such a dereliction of
constitutional duty that is that the
biden has engaged in um
it's egregious it's egregious and it's
also dangerous because well guess what
else is coming across the border
hundreds and hundreds of pounds of
fentanyl okay human trafficking is
occurring at record levels as well so
this is dangerous to our people it's
dangerous because of the pandemic it's
dangerous because of fentanyl overdoses
and it's and it's blatantly unfair and
immoral when considering that there's
thousands of people around the world who
want to come to this country they want
to do it the right way and our system is
so clogged up that they can't do it you
see this poll out congressman that says
56 percent of texans uh hispanic texans
have a view negative view disapproval of
president biden that's not the numbers
that's not the way you turn texas blue
have you noticed that with your
constituents texans that see what's
happening at the border and are not
being won over
yeah that's exactly right
south texas which is largely hispanic is
really turning against democrats because
they're tired of seeing their
communities
overrun by hundreds and hundreds of
illegal immigrants at a time it's
unsustainable it takes away from their
education system from their health care
system uh takes away from their quality
of life look it it infringes like in a
fundamental epidural it infringes on our
national sovereignty and that should
matter to people sometimes but it but
apparently it doesn't for these folks
and look let's just be honest let's
let's stop pretending that the bite
administration and democrats have any
intention of ever enforcing this because
look the reality is they do believe that
they might have a voter block from
hundreds of thousands of new people
coming across that's why they couple
these bad these bad enforcement policies
with um path to citizenship policies on
the back end
but at what cost all right congressman
thank you very much
thank you